with here with your fiance do you go to
the the titty bar
no no dude i haven't been to a titty bar
since i got a fiancee
this is not disrespectful to your fiance
this is many years ago like like 20
years ago when i moved to l.a manny was
in la all the time and uh and we would
go to this this uh titty bar called
crazy girls and uh and manny and minnie
has this way of saying things where he's
not trying to be funny he's just super
just like matter of fact and i thought
it was so great manny said i go to the
titty bar like six or seven nights a
week
that was the office steve will go we go
out at night and steve will go
meet me uh crazy girls and when you go
in there the girls be fighting over
steel oh i don't know about all that
a couple of actual fights out there you
know i did i did call that uh i did call
crazy girls in my office
said we go down the strip and everything
you know but i was not living in l.a you
know did you ever stop by stevo's rad
apartment
yes oh yes i stopped by that in sand
placement
no no it was i don't think any human
being could live there it was a little
the place was i mean
thing being smashed beer cans i mean it
was just a disaster beyond you could i
don't think any human being could live
i've never seen anything like it manny
would rather be in like [ __ ] alligator
waters than that
yes there's less bacteria and something
that alligator water
[Laughter]
that's so great
do you have any cool stories of going to
the apartment do you remember anything
i just remember every time i go in there
you know they broke this they broke that
and then uh you know i was thinking what
are the you know they're gonna the when
the owners of the place they see the
place you know
i'm really thinking what's gonna happen
here another time we went over there was
a party in stevo's house another place
and they're watching uh
the the skateboarder
danny way
yeah yeah anyway whatever and then uh
the next-door neighbors are coming over
and complaining about all the noise and
steel goes look just i don't want to
hear anything like coming in tv look
danny wade is on or uh
variety whatever
what's his name the other one they're on
he goes just come in and watch the show
make sure he knows i'm getting out of
here the cops are coming over all the
noise like neighbors call her
you know i always had back then it was
like noise
music on loud all night long tv crowds
it was just like you know
a human being couldn't keep up with that
you know we were it was like it was
crazy days definitely definitely
definitely crazy i don't know what was
crazier the the
the at work or at home
it was all crazy all the time you
brought work
people how are these guys dude they were
on camera and off camera back in the day
there's just no difference were the
cameras rolling or not all kinds of
crazy things were happening 24 7. nobody
was safe
you better lock the door at night or you
don't know what's gonna happen to you
yeah it was very very unsafe traveling
with uh with a
jackass group it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude